des couleurs des expressions presque des
centeurs il se dégage une atmosphère des
photos de Vincent de louvini l'homme
voyage depuis l'âge de 22 ans son
premier périp il l' accompli en
Indonésie c'est là que l'ivinois s'est
découvert une
passion
un coup de foudre c'est que depuis j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un objectif dans
les yeux quand je voyage voyage je vois
plus les paysages je les vois sur à
travers l'objectif d'un appareil photo
c'est comme si mes yeux étaient devenus
des objectifs Vincent de louvign aime
les bonnes lumières et surtout le petit
détail qui fera que la photo sera
différente comme cette vue de Dublin en
Irlande presque un
tableau quand j'arrive à faire un beau
reflet je l'inverse et ça donne une
toute autre vision de la photo c'estàd
que à l'envers je la trouve moins belle
alors qu'elle interpelle et le but d'une
exposition c'est de se dire mais je je
retrouve pas j'ai vu ce lieu certaines
personnes sont allées à cet endroit il
m'ont dit mais je l'ai pas découvert
tout de suite vous l'avez retouché cette
photo là pas du tout en fait moi je
retouche très peu mes photos plus d'une
centaine de photographies est exposé en
ce moment au conservatoire des arts de
Montini Vincent de louvini a réalisé une
quantaine de voyage cet été il part pour
borneéo un retour aux sources il y a des
paysages qui ressemblent à à d'autres
paysage est qu'on est pas un peu blasé
non parce que les gens sont différents
parce que les les personnes avec qui
vous voyagez on le fait autrement on
fait d'autres rencontres moi le voyage
c'est pas juste des des paysages c'est
les paysages peuvent se ressembler les
personnes qui vivent dans ces pays-là il
ne se ressemblent
jamais